Will Ferrell is preparing for his
farewell to Bush special that will air
an HBO and Broadway in February saying
America I am gonna hold George Bush's
feet to the fire uh will that's cute you
think we care
despite Americans showing time and time
again that we don't care what
celebrities think they continue to show
their political opinions down our throat
but I must feel nice well jumping on the
celebrity bandwagon lining up to take
parting shots the man has become
society's whipping boy but you know who
cares even less what you celebrities
think that Middle America is president
george w bush this man has received more
cheap shots than Daniel Larusso but he's
still standing there like Jake LaMotta
in Raging Bull and never got me down
right you couldn't get me down you never
got me down Hollywood this just fits
with that typical self-important
Hollywood mindset recently Kanye West
deemed himself the black Jesus
Kanye you're not even the black Boy
George Brad Pitt is always in the front
lines to good political and moral advice
you know call me old-fashioned but I
don't want to take advice on anything
from a man with frosted tips from a man
whose lower half was so pathetically
frail they had to use a leg double in
Troy yeah
six-pack abs and biceps but the legs of
a Zambian famine victim
it's just typical Hollywood work the
muscles that show ignore the ones that
matter all showed oh go baby yeah the
point I'm making here is the myth that
is the Hollywood actors physique is
surpassed only by the lie that is their
social or political awareness and how
did he manage Alina Jolie become
Hollywood's golden couple MIT only
wouldn't remember she cheated on his
wife so let's see we've got a temptress
and an adulterer ah they were made for
each other let me ask you this if you
had friends like them in real life do
you think you'd be saying hey there goes
the golden couple or do you think you'd
be saying Tweety Tweety there goes the
Jackass who cheering his life and that's
that's the harlot with him how was Brad
Pitt going to become society's
conscience when the very moral compass
he's been using the guide his own life
is dangling loosely between his
emaciated thighs not to mention as they
say when you're with omen you're with
every person that woman's been with how
does Angie's brother taste I don't know
is it me do you guys care one way the
other what celebrities think tell me
leave your comment
want to know cuz if you guys do really
care we'll be thinking hinging every
word I'll shut up
I say no Hollywood doesn't hold
themselves to a different standard in
Middle America they hold themselves to
no standards whatsoever they are the
worst among us I say if you're an actor
your job is to act do your job and Brad
stop sucking at it